Okay, I'm just going to take you through some of the changes that we're making to the BurpSuite
inspector. So first of all, what is the inspector? It's basically a collapsible side panel that's
available in the message editor next to request and response views, and it provides a way to
analyze and manipulate messages that you send. So just to be clear, we're talking about this bit of the
interface. So what does it do? It allows you to view and edit request data in tables. So we can edit them
inline at this top level view. And we can also go into a drill down view to see more data. It offers inline
decoding features. So these appear when you select text in the editor. And once you go in the drill down
view, if you have an encoded value there, it'll automatically decode it for you. And it's an area
where we're going to utilize for future tools of wizardry. One such feature lately being the tool
that we introduced for James's HTTP2 research. So what's happening with the inspector? Before we
released it, we had some assumptions on what the reception would be like. We knew it would be very
varied. And it would be like Marmite. Some people love it. Some people hate it. And this is because it
introduced a new workflow for users by removing tabs that they previously used into the contextual
side panel. Users don't like change. We know that pretty much. And we felt important features were
missing from the MVP, such as the ability to resize it, to be able to dock it to the left and so on.
So once we released the inspector, we had some great feedback on Twitter. People were loving the
decoding features that we added to it and stating that we made their lives easier. But on the opposite
spectrum of that, people missed the old headers and hex tabs. They wanted the inspector to be
resizable and they'd rather have it on the left. The best tweet that we received was in response to
DAF's video of the new office, which juxtaposed the new office with the repeater UI showing the request,
the response, and the inspector lobbed onto the side. Even better was DAF's reply saying,
that looks fantastic. We'll get the builders in. So I think planning permission is going ahead for that.
So following the launch, we reached out to the Twitter rebels. We conducted interviews with some of
those individuals. We did a survey. And we collated all of that along with telemetry to form the strategy
that we were going to move forward with. So the key insights that we gained from the feedback was that
the inspector was too far away. On the right, you can see a screenshot which was from user feedback,
and they felt the need to add a banana to it for scale. For some users, if they had the inspector
closed, it would be one to two extra clicks. So one click to open the inspector, a second click to open
the widget in which they wanted to view. Some users just didn't have the screen real estate for it.
We've got users on very small laptops, as it turns out. Other users just wanted the tabs back. And
users also wanted more features such as being able to decode JSON web tokens. So I'll just run you
through a prototype that addresses a lot of those changes and helps speed up the user workflow. So
if I open the inspector, we've made some immediate changes to the interface, just simple things like
grouping counters so that there's a consistent area for those. At the top, we've got some inline
options so that we can dot the inspector to the left or to the right. We've got an expand all feature,
which opens all the widgets that contain data. So as you can see here, if we close the inspector
and open it, we're starting to get to a state where the workflow is faster and we haven't got to keep
opening widgets all the time. We've got a collapse all. And we've also introduced a wrapping feature
at the widget level so that cells are wrapped. And that means that it's easier to access and edit the
data with an inline feature that we've already got live. And so we're starting to get somewhere with
this. But we can do more things to help users with their workflow. So we've introduced a configuration
dialogue where users can select the widgets and reorder them in the order that they'd like. We can
choose whether or not to show or hide the widgets. Widgets can be opened by default so that we don't have
to manually open them. And we can set which widgets we want to wrap text by default. So imagine we want
to set request cookies to be always open. Let's hide response headers and let's set all of the widgets to
wrap. We can choose the position of the inspector. So let's dock it to the left and let's set it so that
it's always closed by default. So when I next open a tab or send a request into repeater, this will be my default view.
And when I open it, I'll get the request cookies widget open and the cell data will automatically be wrapped.
But we could still do more. So we can also take the available widgets in the inspector and also add them back in as tabs in the editor,
which is where the real power of this comes in as the user can start to configure their own workspace.
So we can turn on headers, params, cookies and attributes and save that.
As you can see, they now appear in the message editor.
The advantage of this is that we're using the inspector widgets themselves rather than going back to the old view,
meaning that we can auto wrap cell data. They have the decoding features at the drill down view.
And you can also view the view as a table with the inspector open with the inline decoding available.
So what we've done is we've allowed the user to configure their workspace so that all the workflow is available within one banana.
So the work for this is due to go live in a week or two for phase one.
The guys are working really hard on it and we hope this is going to make a good impact.
Thank you.